Let's get started with EMFI
with Johnlair. Good round of applause,
please. [applause]
[applause]
Testing. Okay.
Bonjourus Avenue. Good afternoon
everyone. Welcome to the talk.
As you can see, I'm giving a talk on
EMFI, electromagnetic fault injection. I
apologize for the title. I came up with
it in an airport right before the
deadline. So that's what I got. It's
embarrassing, but that's how it is.
About me quickly.
My name is Johnlair. I actually met a
lot of my family lives here in Quebec.
However, I'm a first generation American
living in Florida. It's actually really
cold here.
>> [clears throat]
>> I've been working as a principal
embedded systems engineer for the
department of defense and DARPA and
currently at Blue Rock IO for probably
20 years now mainly on fourth and fifth
generation NATO fighter aircraft and
tactical SDRs.
I specialize in uh BSP development FPJAS
secure boot cryptography
hardware reverse engineering
countermeasures and anti-tampering. And
recently I've been working with the Nova
hypervisor if anyone's familiar and
putting it on embedded systems on
aircraft.
I also do a lot of side channel analysis
and reverse engineering. Uh most of the
stuff I can't put on here. It's
classified.
Previously I worked as a software
developer [clears throat]
and security researcher at a small
startup called Pivix a long time ago.
I did a lot of malawware
root analysis and prevention software
and I spent a lot of time under IDA pro
staring at massively online online role
playing games pentesting for a large
company.
Here's my contact information. Only
thing you need to get out of this if you
want the slides it's in my GitHub.
Uh I will answer any question anybody
asked me if I can. Some of it's
classified again, but I'm really
passionate about this. So, anybody any
questions, just ask me. Come up to me in
the conference, ask me more questions.
So, this is where I got started.
I'm a little older. I was actually one
of the last people to get one of these
before the Super NES's came out.
I started a fault injection career by
just power cycling power as fast as I
could until I got the helicopter to fly
backwards. And that was my goal. And it
was great. I could pick up people that I
missed when they were when I was going
by them. It was perfect. That was the
start of my career. Actually, [snorts]
I'm not sure I'm going to even read
this. Kind of boring. Uh the man page
electromagnetic fault injection. A fault
injuration technique utilizing powerful
electromagnetic pulses to cause a fault
in order to conduct physical attacks
against integrated circuits. In other
words, glitching.
Why this talk?
I'd really like to get every more people
interested in reverse engineering
community. Does not have to be
expensive. You don't have to be
electrical or hardware engineer. And for
about $30, you can create a small test
bed with a AT mega 256 2560 Arduino and
a barbecue igniter.
It's all you really need.
I also plan on providing source code to
show what really happens after you move
the XY platter stage. A lot of
companies, a lot of researchers, they
don't share any of this, how they do it.
They just give you the code to move a
platter. That's it. I'm going to release
their secret sauce.
I'm going provide a simple examples on
how to autonomously and via programmatic
programmatic methods locate and
determine CPU register locations as well
as detect if there's a attempt was
successful fault.
How fault injection techniques attack a
device? It basically just manipulates
bits. It flips bits, CPU registers and
RAM to modify outcome of exe executing
software. We can also control the width
of a clock cycle to skip over machine
instructions. We can also disable
security. So we can get so we can use
J-tag
or unlock secure locations that stores
the proprietary firmware and flash
memory.
If we if we hit a if we hit a fault
exactly during an if then else, we can
change the outcome of that if then else
statement in a in source code.
Am I speaking too fast? I know it's a
lot I got a lot of slides. So,
advantages of EM fault injection. It's
touchless. Uh voltage and voltage
glitching typically requires removing
bypass capacitors off the board, other
things. uh removing potting if it was a
military board that was captured on a
certain battlefield.
For example,
[clears throat]
this clock uh where are we? EM fault
injection also has very small spatial
resolution, narrow beam focus. It
typically does not affect components on
the entire board. On the other hand,
voltage injection usually glitches the
entire board and messes up other
portions of their hardware.
EMP pulses. You can also hit the bottom,
strike the bottom of a target of a
printed circuit board and through potted
or conformal coated boards. As I said
before, if they were trying to hide
their anti-tamper boards, this will go
right through it.
It's just some fun maybe you want to
look up someday is uh previous fault
injection work. Joe Grant did he hacked
a treasure 1 hardware wallet that was a
voltage glitch. You can break ARMbased
trust zone secure boot implementations
including tablets. You can turn you can
unlock stem32
uh security features and you can
actually modify the AES calculations on
small micros processors and FPJs that's
all on EMFI also
very important safety
very important I found out
[clears throat] really did um some of
these devices generate over 100 thousand
volts of of power voltage uh 1 jew
High voltage is always flowing through
the EMP probe. It's when you release it
quickly, it causes a EMF EMF pulse.
High voltage charge remains for minutes
even after powering down.
Always powering down, unplug, wait 5
minutes before changing EMF probe tips.
Always cover your EMF probes and layers
with layers of heat shrink tubing or
electrical tape. That's where I went
wrong. I wasn't thinking. and I grabbed
a hold of a tip and I lost feeling for
about an hour. It was it was it was
brutal.
So, now we'll get back. Now we get into
the actual devices. As I said before,
Barbecq Pio spark igniter. $3.
Another $3 for a ferite core inductor.
You have yourself a 1000vt EMF glitch
device. Fully capable of glitching
hardware, CPU registers, RAM, etc. It's
fun. It's quickly. I use it. I still use
it to verify my setups for impress your
significant other, too.
Didn't even work on my children.
Okay, so it works fast, but not so fast.
We want repeatable results. The barbecue
pork igniter is a mechanical push button
timing. It's very difficult to keep the
probe in an exact spot and you cannot
control the MP voltage and discharge
impulse shape.
So, let's go on to some more low-end
devices. Maybe some of you familiar with
new AE devices. He gen uh Colin Ollin.
He he created a Pico EMP. It's about
$133. Open source open hardware.
And there's a Ledger silicone toaster.
It's also open source open hardware. I
do make those. I'm not trying to
advertise it. They're paying to make,
but I do make them for friends and a
couple of university professors. Anybody
wants one, I can make them one, too.
There's another one I just discovered
recently. It's called the Faulty Cat.
It's sold out of Mexico, I believe. It's
practically similar to the Pico EMP. It
appears to be in stock, unlike New A
stores. It's never in stock. I have not
tested it, though.
New store does create great devices by
Colin Flynn. He's uh probably the
godfather of hardware hacking, sort of.
Uh he he creates a tool called the chip
shouter. I've used it. It comes with
many targets you can try out, but it's
about $5,000 and it's really hard to
get. It's scarce.
I also discovered this recently and
actually shocked myself again on this
one just a couple days ago. $12.
Electronic push button igniter. It's
possibly workable. I haven't gotten that
far yet. I know it generates a spark.
You can also create active timing with
it since it's not manually being
manipulated. You can also control it
with a via CPIO GPIO pin and char
recharge extremely quickly.
Little things about EM probe tips. We
got a they're usually about $3 to5 each.
You make them yourself. I don't think
anybody really sells them. One thing to
note, they are polarized depending on
how they're wired up.
You can use small to large for different
spatial resolutions. very narrow
surgical resolution to the Hail Mary,
which I use to make sure something's
even working. The middle ampia probe is
what most manufacturers sell with their
equipment.
Additional equipment, discarded 3D
printers or CNC machines. They act as
great XY stages.
Uh, most people can probably find one
for free. They probably have a printer
that they don't use anymore, one of the
older ones. You can modify it very
quickly. As I said, it functions as an
XY stage. It allows accurate recon of
entire chip or board. Can accurately
position the EMP probe to a known active
position. You can program at the fuzzled
active position until it actually finds
the exact position where a fault occurs.
That's my setup right there on the left.
Unfortunately, sometimes when you
hit a hit a board with an EMP, it
crashes the system. you lose connection
to the USB serial port and you can't get
it get anything done. So, you probably
pretty much need a $20 USB control
relay,
put it in in your software, you can
detect that the the USB connection has
crashed via a timer thread or whatever
and then you can restart it via the
relay board.
Now, we can play around with some
targets.
First, we need to some selection hints.
Choose a board with a CPU that's very
large or a RAM size, a RAM chip that's
very large in size. It's just easier to
strike a position.
Make sure it has a an inexpensive
debugging hardware or software, serial
wire debugger, JTAG or open OCD support,
and make sure those those devices are
have a Python library to support them.
>> [snorts]
>> So now we have the targets that I use
pretty much daily or weekly at least.
The new AE ballistic gel, I use that to
characterize a new EMP probe. Test the
new EMP probe. However, I only think
it's shipped with the new AA chip
shatter. Now it's a $5,000 device, so it
might be out of reach.
So there's a However, it's open source,
so you can readily make your own.
There's readily available clones. Again,
I do manufacture and sell these. I won't
say anymore. I'm not pushing my
products, but if anybody wants one, I
can make them one, too. Arduino boards
had Arduinos. The Mega 2560 is very
large, so it's very easy to scan around
it the around this part looking for
active locations. Stem 32 nuclear
boards, I use one of those because it
comes with a built-in software or serial
wire debugger.
And I do a lot of work with the Xylink
Zinc 7000 and the Xyink Zinc Ultra Scale
Plus. A lot of that's part of is for
work though.
So now we're at the point where we can
actually do a recon of a chip where we
just scan every possible position on a
chip at intervals of let's say 1
millimeter or half a millimeter. To do
that, we just need to halt the
processor. And then we just configure
RAM and registers with known values.
Inject the pulse, read back the values,
compare and mark as no ch no change RAM
changes or register changes. Gives you
an idea of where you can start looking
to hunt down vulnerabilities.
Here's just a picture of the new AA
ballistic gel. I again I highly re
recommend using it. It's my most trusted
device to check out new features of my
EMFI devices or probes. It does show a
spread of the beam.
So, here we are actually doing a XY
scan, a recon of the actual ballistic
gel. We're going every possible XY
position, blasting each point, and
coming up with results at 375 volts
with a positive polarity tip. You can
see you have a a bank on the top, a bank
on the bottom, and over to the left, um,
probably control the control control
registers.
On the right, you can see there is a
polarity difference. I switched polarity
tips. And now you cannot see the memory
banks. There's two of them, you know,
upper and one on the top and one on the
lower that don't show up with the
reverse polarity. Now, I feel kind of
stupid because when I first tested the
ballistic gel, I set my probe right in
the center of the chip and I nothing
happened. So, I thought there was
something wrong. I didn't really realize
that the banks were on the on the sides.
So that's why we do a recount of a chip.
Here we do the same thing with a um with
the ballistic gel. However, we're just
hitting the memory banks. As you can see
at 7,000 volts, I am I am saturating
bit flips. We're I'm saturating bit
flips on all the array uh on all the
array rows. If you zoom in, you can see
almost every single bite has been
changed other than a few. If I was to do
this at a thousand volts, either the
ballistic gel might destroy itself or I
knock every change every bit.
Here I'm doing a recon of the STM
nucleus board nuclear board. It's about
I think it's about $25 board
and you can see where it's found things
for more active uh more research later.
So that's that's that's scanning
reconnaissance XY positioning. But now
we need to figure out when to actually
fire off a a pulse.
You could do the random method, but
that's that's not science science. So we
want to kind of go more scientifically.
So you utilize side channel analysis
tools to detect a condition and trigger
the injection. You can use a chip
whisperer, open ADC, fi whisper. That's
what I use to do USB analysis of a
bootloader. And I also use Hfield probe
data. It's also a good idea to use the
same hardware and development SDK as the
manufacturer is using because they very
rarely change from the stock
bootloaders.
These are side channel tools I use
regularly. A modified edis SDR
to log and analyze Hfield probe data
chip whisperer light the husky and the
fire whisper as I mentioned before.
If I can switch to a video demonstration
real quick. It's not the best.
It's kind of boring. I'm going to
mention a few things. Oh, wait. Oh,
shoot. Sorry. Let me switch back.
Initially, I wrote this in C++ and mat
lab. So, I'm in the process of
converting to Python and Numpy. Still
work in progress. Many to-dos, many
porting classes. Uh,
I'm going to show that we can modify the
general purpose registers in an an
Arduino 2560.
I was struck by some demo video
gremlins. So, I'm going to do a little
bit of head hawking in this video. I'll
explain in a minute. I made this right
before getting on an airplane on Monday.
So,
shouldn't have done that.
So, here's a tool that I'm running. Uh,
it's it takes a couple of arguments.
the the location of your
tools. Now I select the target. You can
see there's xylink tools s gel arduino
etc. CT one down the right oh lower
right hand corner you can see the probe.
It's going to move in a minute. I'm
choosing single shot. Just fires one one
one off. Tell it where I want it to
shoot.
And we're gonna continually try pulses
because I'm not going to be lucky on the
first pulse. So, I'm going to fuzz it a
little bit to find the sweet spot.
Select six 600 volts.
Okay, now it's charging up.
And now the the probe's going to move.
It's going to start hitting. You can see
where the Arduino is counting one, two,
three, one at a second.
And it keeps shoot. It keeps hitting the
Arduino waiting for it to change
something. So, I had that wait two
minutes. So, I took it out and it's in
it's at the end of this video where
you'll see what it does to it. But just
as simple like you could do the same
thing with a barbecue sparker. It's
coming right up. I grabbed the wrong
video when I was editing.
Come on. Oh, that's embarrassing.
Come on.
Any second now.
So now you can see it's no longer doing
one and one second intervals. We we
successfully modified actual control
registers in the Arduino. In addition,
it's not counting normal numbers
anymore. We hit the registers that were
used to store the count value.
[applause and cheering] A little bit
more.
But you could do that for $20. $25. I
might be exaggerating. I'm used to kind
of talking to my wife on buying things.
So I used I had to use GU to prove that
it was actually using the registers
instead of actually changing memory
locations. But here's that code in the
near future. Yes. In summary, u my main
job is busting OPI trust zones for ARM
archite
arch 64 architecture. Yes, I can break
particular tablet secure bootloadader to
own the device. That was my initial
talk. I don't have any lawyers, so I
decided not to. So I also can change the
entropy and random number generation,
but again no lawyers. Hopefully legally
hopefully to legally present this work
in the near future. And here's some of
the important links. New AE, the uh
silicone toaster, the presentation
slides, the faulty cat.
Any questions? I know anybody still
maybe wants.
[applause]